Has tenido la edición mínima en tus
manos durante las últimas 48 horas. Ya viste
el trap score. Sentiste lo que es
tener un escudo. Pero mientras tú
miras el score, las ballenas ya están
evolucionando. La edición mínima
te muestra la puerta, pero el protocolo
completo te muestra toda la sala.
Ahora mismo, los algoritmos institucionales
están creando señales falsas para activar tu
FOMO. Cuando la trampa se cierre, un escudo
mínimo podría no ser suficiente. Necesitas la
suite completa de inteligencia visual. Cuatro motores
de IA: Grok, GPT, Gemini y
CryptoQuant trabajando en sincronía. Seguimiento
de ballenas en tiempo real, filtros de sentimiento,
decisiones en 3 segundos. Esto no es
solo trading, es una ventaja injusta.
Para celebrar a nuestros nuevos defensores,
abrimos la campaña del protocolo. Solo para
las próximas 50 personas, puedes desbloquear
todo con un 50% de descuento. Es protección
institucional completa por menos de
un dólar al día. Pero cuando esos 50 cupos
se llenen, este enlace expirará y el
precio se duplicará. No dejes tu capital
a la suerte. Mejora tu protocolo
de defensa. Usa el código defend50 en el checkout
ahora mismo. Bienvenido a la academia completa.
Ganemos juntos.